in 1966 a pivotal moment in American
democracy occurred with the
establishment of the Freedom of
Information Act colloquially known as
foia congressman John Moss spearheaded
this legislation which fundamentally
reshaped the power dynamics by demanding
government transparency the Bill's
implementation aimed to satisfy the Need
For answers and accountability initially
met with resistance from Lyndon Johnson
foia eventually received his signature
on July 4th symbolically reinforcing the
freedom it sought to Grant over time the
foia underwent amendments notably in
1974 after the Watergate scandal and
again in 1996 to adapt it to the digital
ERA this tool has been utilized by
journalists activists and ordinary
citizens to penetrate the bureaucratic
barriers and expose the inner workings
of those in power despite its inherent
imperfections Voya remains as one of the
few safeguards against governmental
secrecy